upscale west hollywood votes to defund
sheriff department even as crimes soars
to 137
while savings will be used to fund 30
unarmed security ambassadors and a
russian arts festival now keep in mind
this is an article i'm reading so
forgive me if you don't agree with the
article let me just finish the article
here
uh papa papa here we go west oliver city
council has voted to defund the
sheriff's department despite crime
rocketing 137 percent
the proposal passed by narrow three to
two votes we'll see the current force of
around 60 sheriff deputies reduced by
four funds saved by reducing the head
count
will be used to pay for unarmed security
ambassadors under a scheme called block
by block despite slashing the police
policing budget the council agreed to
stump
up funds for russian arts festival
increasing their contribution from
fourteen thousand to fifty thousand
and then uh lauren uh mester i believe
if i'm pronouncing it correctly
democratic mayor of west hollywood and a
member of the council who voted against
the plan called it illogical
noting that the los angeles enclave is
afflicted by rising tide of violence so
having said that seppi if i'm not
mistaken you were the leader in uh uh
causing this change yes if i'm not
mistaken
um so here's the thing um i made the
motion
and there's a lot of misinformation out
there about what we did what we actually
did monday night was go through and
approve our entire budget
what we did with regard to our community
safety department which has nothing to
do with the russian arts festival
that's a completely different budget
line item
we actually increased our public safety
department budget as a whole we
reallocated funding within the
department and increased public safety
funds this whole
wording about oh they're defunding the
police this is actually not what the
defund the police movement was
supposed to be defunding the police
movement
was about
slashing
officers
and putting that money into social
services what we did do is on a
different budget item increased social
services by a million dollars but it had
nothing to do with this we have a proven
program called block by block security
ambassadors which by the way the mayor
herself brought forward two items to
increase their presence on our east side
which was having a lot of crime in
commercial corridors earlier this year
and that proved really successful and
then throughout the commercial corridors
in this same budget we increased six
kiosks for our businesses and 36
full-time block by block ambassadors so
it's really disappointing
that
she
supports this program for businesses but
when it comes to residents who want foot
patrols she thinks it's it's not
successful and that's just a rhetoric
she's using to get reelected frankly um
excuse me
excuse me jedidiah here i i just had a
question for you um you know because the
the original defund the police movement
the motivation was actually to
reallocate money but it was to remove
money from police and move it into other
aspects oftentimes people suggested
social workers
other options that were not so what i'm
trying to get to the bottom ups here i
don't know what a block by block
ambassador is here but ultimately you
have a problem in this area of
california with crime i think we can all
acknowledge that so is there going to be
money a that leaves the sheriff's
department that is going to cause less
police officers to be available to be on
the street and if so what is the
alternative to that are you going to
advocate for second amendment rights for
citizens
what is the alternative because safety
has to come from somewhere and if you
can't call the police what do you do
sure so here's the thing our residents
have wanted us to have foot patrols in
neighborhoods
and the
deputies in the sheriff's department
their
pay has increased substantially over the
past 10 years almost doubled is the foot
not to interrupt are the foot patrols
armed are those people going to be armed
as police officers would be no they are
not armed okay so
so what happens
there are block by block security
ambassadors that have proved successful
to deter crimes are they
are the security ambassadors armed no no
no no
okay so i have a question for you though
because the criminals are armed
criminals are most of the time armed
with something so if a criminal has a
gun we know criminals don't obey laws
they get a gun they get a hold of a gun
they see
they they they set out to cause crime to
rob assault whatever it may be
and they're not confronted with someone
who is armed what is that person going
to do get shot what what happens there
is that is that are you how are you
envisioning that conversation because to
me
it seems that
someone who's trained someone who has
passed their background checks someone
who is a a a citizen who is armed or
someone who is a police officer would be
the best person for that criminal to
meet on the street not someone who's
going to try to talk them out of
committing a crime i'm curiously curious
of your thoughts yeah sure here's the
thing we have trained our block by block
ambassadors and crime doesn't just
happen in an isolated place in the city
of west hollywood it happens all over
and we have proven that these block by
block ambassadors actually determine
deter criminals we literally have proof
of that
um and right now
they have not been um
under harm doing their job they've been
doing a fantastic job but
look at the crime rate in the area right
so
by the way if they're doing a great job
why does the crime rate look like it
does the 137 by the way is also
factually untrue that was a point in
time and literally
um
the problem with percentages is you're
looking at something if if if there was
one robbery and then it became two over
six months that's a hundred percent
increase the fact is if you we looked at
all the numbers and all the stats of
crimes and
the
2019 numbers were actually higher than
2021. of course 2020 was low because
crime fell because people mostly were
locked into their homes um so these
these percentages um
really create more fear and they're
they're actually not based on what the
truth is and so the block by block
security ambassador is
works in our commercial corridors and
it's going to work in our residential
and we're doing this in a very pragmatic
slow way we're going to be decreasing
two deputies in 90 days and we actually
added one extra deputy so the net total
in 90 days will actually be one we've
had issues in our nightlife district at
night so we're adding one entertainment
policing deputy and then nine months
from now we're going to re-evaluate the
program happy canadian can i ask you a
question um
with the client let me finish we're
going to see what the crime stats are in
nine months and in nine months if the
program is successful we may reduce
three more deputies and this is 60
deputies versus then 56 in total
potentially sepi can i a legitimate
question because i come from new york
city which struggles with crime as of
late it's one of the reasons i moved was
because i have a two and a half year old
and i couldn't justify living in a city
where the truly the police force didn't
feel supported and also second amendment
rights aren't exactly upheld for
individuals in new york city how do you
feel what do you say to someone like me
uh i'm a young woman i'm pretty small in
size and stature i like the idea of a
police force that feels supported and i
like the idea of a strong second
amendment because i know that if i'm met
on a street corner by someone who wants
to do harm to me or my child i want
someone i want i want the good guy with
the gun be it a police officer or myself
to be able to counter that person what
do you say to someone who hears this and
hears you know about ambassadors and
social workers and just doesn't feel
confident and comfortable living in a
city where that is the alternative and
the antithesis that's presented to a
criminal walking around with a gun who
seeks to do harm what do you say to me
first of all what i say to you is um i
understand your fear
i understand your fear um and honestly
as a woman um i myself uh
have had fears walking streets and what
i will also say is looking at the actual
crime stats
um
they're not as high as the media is
making them seen and spinning them but
it's not just a media game step because
i've been in i've been in weho and i've
been in new york city it's real it's
tangible it's on the ground so i mean do
you support the second amendment are you
a second amendment advocate if someone
wanted to go and follow the proper
protocol and they said this is my city
they're decreasing the police force this
is my opportunity to step in and defend
myself and my family would you support
that
uh defend yourself and your family in
what way yeah say i wanted to get a gun
say i wanted to follow protocol and i
said there's less police on the streets
i don't trust that i don't want to pick
up my phone and know that resources have
been cut and maybe there's a five minute
delay on when that police officer
arrives because there's less of them
this is a decision being made say in
california so i want to go and i want to
get a gun to protect myself and my
family follow proper protocol pass that
you know the checks do you support that
listen um we
now live in a different america
with people being able to uh now carry
concealed weapons we don't california
has not analyzed what our laws are with
respect to no but i'm asking you i'm
asking you if you support is if someone
if someone
um
under the law needs to defend themselves
then they can defend themselves and what
i would say to you just to finish up on
that is
we have tested this program
our residents have wanted foot patrols
in our residential streets and we are
giving them
30 boots on the ground and we're doing
it in a
pragmatic way which brings public safety
but also
slowly phases out literally actually the
total of one deputy in 90 days that is
something that will give more public
safety to people and we're going to
monitor the program
and see what happens in nine months
those people those people better be
prepared in my opinion to do some combat
i mean if you're telling me those people
go and train to be i mean you're talking
about boots on the ground they better i
mean are they kickboxing experts because
people who intend to perform they're
already on the top they're already on
the ground they're already on the ground
so we know that's what i'm saying look
at the crime they're already all over
the city in the commercial areas which
actually have a higher amount of crime
than everywhere else so they've already
been tested and um they've been
successful i've actually said this is
vince norton here i actually witnessed
this first hand i was uh i was working
doing stand-up auditioning doing all my
stuff working security in north
hollywood on magnolia
and lancaster which is all little
restaurants and and you know you know
little diners and you know it's really
it's popping coffee shops and all that
stuff and there was always i want to say
three or four because i was working
security the safety ambassadors that you
were speaking of that you know they were
the yellow shirts and no gun and they
and they patrol i did i personally
didn't see any
less crime i mean the fighting and
everything was still happening the only
thing that they were responding to from
where i was at was the homeless
situation like when homeless people were
starting to you know fight or argue or
you know they were doing drugs they were
called and there was instances where we
needed the cops called that's all that
they were doing was calling the cops for
us which we could have done ourselves
there was a guy that had a knife and i
was like oh my god the safety ambassador
does not get involved they just called
9-1-1 and i was like i could have done
exactly what you just did so i i'd be
interested to see if the the numbers do
change because at the end of the day the
cop was called and if we're getting less
cops and that they're not getting
motivated to come help i don't i don't
see how that would help the the crime
rate
we're in a partnership with the
sheriff's department um we're not
getting rid of them we're actually also
by the way looking at a feasibility
study to create our own municipal police
department too
what is the motivation
if you don't mind me asking what is the
motivation to cut you you know you
emphasized oh it's only one officer what
is the motivation behind the cut overall
why do you want to make that cut
sure fiscal responsibility because we
had to pass a budget
and
one
sheriff's deputy equals 4.6 block by
block ambassadors so it is it is
balancing a budget
and reallocating the funding to another
department that's an alternative it is
something new and i understand
the fear people have
when
people try new things and this is a new
alternative that is actually not new in
our city and by the way um regarding
north hollywood i don't know about north
hollywood we're city of west hollywood
and our block by block program has
worked yeah i mean i agree with you on
fiscal responsibility you and i can
agree on that point i'm a fiscal
responsibility girl i'm somebody who
look you know you should line item but
look at that budget see what cut you can
but i'm just going to say to you that
it's not realistic in my opinion to if
you're going to go for fiscal
responsibility the last area you should
be looking at in a place that does have
exponentially high crime is cutting the
police force it seems to me that there
must be some political motivation
involved here there was political
motivation involved in the defund the
police movement at large and i'm just
i'm just going to put a warning out
there that
if you throw out i don't care if it's a
social worker i don't care who it is if
they're unarmed and they're just going
to seek to keep the peace it's an
admirable goal it's an admirable gesture
but if they are faced with people who
intend to do harm who are armed that's
going to be a problem and there are
going to be families moms dads that are
going to take one look around at that
and they're going to say i need to take
this job on to myself if there's not
going to be an active police officer to
do what they can and should be doing in
this space so i would not be surprised
if you see people going and get
registering for their gun licenses and
seeing news stories like this in in
places like uh you know weho or wherever
it may be new york city i've seen it
happen in new york city already and you
see you know citizens feeling like they
need to now do the job the police
officers should be doing because they're
concerned that a defund the police
movement isn't prioritizing safety
that's just my opinion so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]